these people they actively work against
Civil Society it's not just the case
that you don't get in trouble for
breaking the law you do get in trouble
for stopping somebody from breaking the
law yeah and so this is what the media
has made perfectly clear to the American
people over the past several years and
this is something they've believed for
decades but they've gotten explicitly
clear in their messaging about this we
saw this during the 2020 riots right 30
people died the vast majority of people
don't know any of their names but
everyone knows Kyle's Kyle rittenhouse's
name do you know why because he defended
himself he didn't let the mob murder him
and that's not what he was supposed to
do he was supposed to allow himself to
be killed and he didn't which is why he
needs to be charged because he's setting
an example for people he's showing
people that you don't have to roll over
and die because a lesson when mob is
rioting in your neighborhood or a
neighborhood that you're invested in
protecting